okay so let's now get to this just crazy
dishonest story from kenosha wisconsin
where where the term crisis actor which
is often a staple of right wing
conspiracy theorists
it almost works in this story take a
listen to this so yesterday donald trump
went to kenosha wisconsin
the mayor didn't want him there the
governor didn't want him there
this was the site of unrest over the
weekend last week in fact
and this is the location where 17 year
old kyle rittenhouse was involved
in shooting multiple people killing
people and
ultimately charged with homicide this is
the place this is the epicenter
and it turns out that there was a
business
burned down in kenosha
which is a century-old camera shop
and it's owned by tom graham now tom
graham that's g-r-a-m
not g-r-a-a-h-a-m just tom graham gram
tom graham was invited to participate in
a photo op with donald trump
um in front of the burned down shop
and he refused he refused because he
realized he was going to be used as a
political
prop and he said i'm not going to
participate in that
but if you watched the event it
certainly seemed like the owner
of that camera shop was there and the
reason
is that they brought in a different guy
they brought in the previous owner of
the camera shop they got a stand-in they
got a guy to
act in this crisis as if it has hit
as if it was his business that burned
down
uh if you look at the picture you see
john
road now it's road camera shop so that
makes sense right well no
because john road hasn't been the owner
of road camera shop
for eight years check out this video
from the event
so this store was here 109 years
just about the oldest in the nation
doing work
in the state for sure that's fantastic
and we're going to help them
a lot i think we're going to help them a
lot would you like to say something
i just appreciate president trump coming
today
everybody here does we're so thankful
that
we got the federal troops in to help
because once they got here
things did calm down quite a bit and our
city uh
police and sheriff and fire departments
are awesome
they worked harder than you can believe
24 7.
that's true these gentlemen did a
fantastic job
working with the federal government and
it was really uh
great and once we said let's go
that was the end of it unfortunately
they had a few days
when people wouldn't call us they didn't
want to have us come in they just don't
want us to come in and then destruction
is done
a day early we would have saved your
store one day early one day early
yeah except it's not actually
this guy's store the actual owner
immediately refused to participate
saying quote
i think everything he does meaning trump
i think everything he does turns into a
circus
and i just didn't want to be involved in
it and
he watched on tv tom graham saw on tv
trump show up and talked to the former
owner
and saw john road commend donald trump
in his response to the unrest in kenosha
and uh congratulate trump for
sending in troops and all of this other
stuff
is this a crisis actor and i'm not
really saying it i mean okay
it's a term that right-wing conspiracy
theorists love to use when it doesn't
apply
when we had the horrible horrible
shooting
school shooting at sandy hook in
connecticut
you had alex jones and others talking
about these are crisis
actors there are no real victims so on
and so forth i think ultimately alex
jones had to backtrack on that because
he got sued
but many others were saying it as well
crisis actors is a phrase a term that
they love to use
that actually seems to be a term that
applies
in this particular case and uh it has
not been this guy's store
for eight years and yet he is presented
as if it is his business that has burned
down
now tmj4 news reached out to the white
house
to ask why did trump
claim that that was the business owner
when that is not the business owner and
the business owner in fact
opted out of participating here they
have not yet
responded with a comment and i am sure
that they either will not respond or
will come up with some justification as
opposed to saying
we made a mistake why because donald
trump has never said
that he has made a mistake and it is all
in continuing with the so earlier in the
show
i read a quote from aaron rupar who i
follow on twitter and he posts a lot of
great content
and aaron said what exactly is the point
of these visits to places like kenosha
the authorities don't want the officials
don't want trump there he just shows up
and meets with sycophants and pretends
that everybody is just so grateful for
him and then he leaves
that is the point and when you see this
case where the actual owner of the
camera shop said keep me the hell out of
it
and they get the guy who hasn't owned it
for eight years to stand there with
trump
it is all optics it doesn't the truth
doesn't matter
from the point of view of the image that
donald trump is
trying to create what matters is can you
find somebody to praise me
that's what trump cares about and that's
exactly what they did here
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors sussman and
han
sussman and han has everything you need
when it comes to face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off sussman and han is the company that
i personally have been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor
i have tried tons of different masks
this year
and i still have not found a mask that's
more comfortable or easier to breathe in
than the washable cotton masks that they
sell it's made of a silky lightweight
cotton that feels great on your skin
it has convenient adjustable straps it
features a disposable five-layer
particle filter made of activated carbon
they also have disposable cloth masks
which are really comfortable as well as
other gear
like face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love sussman and han
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions they're
a great company
you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is underneath this video
and you can save
twenty percent off of everything in
their store when you use the coupon code
david